the service dogs in training from doggie
do good have a big day ahead of them
it's beach day the Sun the surf and
boundless distractions that could cause
any of these dogs to flunk out of
service dog school this is puppy Prem
[Music]
none of the pups are more excited to
smell that ocean air than
eight-month-old golden retriever Luke
he's been hanging out by the beach since
he was only a couple months old his
half-sister Remi is also excited maybe
too excited it's alright for her to take
a second and adjust to the new sights
and smells but when it comes time for
work
Remi is going to need to focus for these
puppies the first order of business had
any new location is to sample the local
grass while they're not supposed to chew
on the foliage it's easy for the pups to
sneak a bite when the trainers have
their backs turned and the trainer's
turn their backs frequently having this
many puppies around draws attention and
people are excited to learn about the
service dogs Benelli and Remi are taking
this chance to mess around the dogs
aren't supposed to go on the sand after
attack and while special exception can
be made for service animals there's no
shortage of other activities by the
ocean like the playground the playground
offers a multitude of different surfaces
sounds and experiences all of this
builds confidence getting the puppies
ready for anything first one up
six-month-old chocolate lab Benelli
climbing on rocks and walking on sand
may appear simple but it's actually
building the puppy's comfort on a
variety of surfaces where ever Benelli
goes she needs to be focused not on
where she's standing but on what her
owner may need after breezing through
the different surfaces it's time for
something that will really disorient
the slide while Bonelli's future owners
may never actually take her down a slide
it's important she has confidence to
handle all kinds of new experiences at
first she's nervous but with some
coaxing and the promise of a treat
even a puppy like Benelli can find her
courage now back on firm land the
trainer is sure to praise Benelli up
building a connection in the puppy's
mind between bravery and reward fresh
off the excitement of the slide trainer
Paul tosses his keys to ensure Benelli
still knows its work time and she
happily does her job there's still one
more slide for Benelli to attempt the
spiral slide that is if she can get up
to it with a bit of a running start
she makes the leap her lesson from the
other slide has her excited to try this
one
having never seen them before five
minutes ago slides are now simple for
the six-month-old chocolate lab
back with the dogs and down-stay karen
tries to refocus Remy she tries to get
the golden to heal and focus in but the
eight-month-old won't settle down this
isn't good
Remy's future owner will count on her
day in and day out and it looks like
Remy's lack of focus is starting to
spread Luke get back come on
Karen's trying to focus on Remy kaya are
you serious come on all three golden
said the sillies now even usually
dependable Luke kaya has to refocus and
quick it's her turn to walk the
playground the eight month old enjoys
jumping on different surfaces the
straight slide and when it's time for
the spiral slide what was a tough jump
for Benelli is an easy hop for kaya but
what goes up must come down and kai is
confused how that's supposed to happen
when Zandi the owner of doggy do good
leads the way
kaya eventually figures it out she's
immediately praised for her bravery a
second attempt on the slide
[Music]
good try kya good try but what's
important is that Chi is conquered her
fear and admirably so back in the
downstate it looks like Remi is finally
calling Oh relax Remi it's just a bird
all right
good girl Remi thank goodness you're
finally starting to show some
self-control otherwise today could have
been the day you failed it oh no braking
from a downstate to this degree is a bad
sign
with Karen working with kiyah Paul has
to leave the dogs to find where Remi ran
off even though they're unsupervised
they don't dare to break no one wants
the fate that's about to befall Remi
lockdown Remi now has to think about
what she's done and hope it doesn't mean
expulsion now it's Luke's turn to take a
lap around the playground his first
challenge is the rocking horse Karen is
trying to get Luke to jump over it in
preparation for future awkward spaces
Luke is not having it he hasn't had
problems with bravery in the past so
this is a new issue eventually our hero
figures it out and Karen is sure to
reward his courage
[Music]
if fluke shows the same hesitation on
the slide then well nevermind looks like
after only a couple attempts he's
already a pro good job buddy when Luke
returns to down-stay he finds deacon is
still getting used to his harness he's
not quite sure why he can't flip all the
way over on his back
Paul straightens him out and it's back
to down stead
okay Remy you've had a tough day so far
it's a time to redeem yourself on the
playground first up is the rocking horse
that Luke struggled with just like with
her half brother it's a matter of
confidence
and it suddenly looks like Remy's lost
most of hers the culprit the pirate-ship
steering wheel notice our tails tucked
between her legs so do the trainers
they're hyper aware of the pups attitude
and this is a huge signal from Remy
Karen gets down on Remy's level and
starts feeding her treats she pets her
and praises her trying to show Remy
she's safe
Remy then has to pass by the wheel
several more times ensuring the dog has
confronted her fear if Karen can get
Remy to sniff the wheel or be still next
to it that's going to be a great
indication that Remy's making progress
eventually a sniff and after a few more
laps her tail starts to wag again
Remy's done extremely well and with so
much excitement already had on the
playground the slide can wait for
another day
back on the grass the undeniable mr.
Pitt finds himself in an embarrassing
situation because he is by far the worst
at downs day mr. pip has to be tied up
to the other dogs Luke seems confused
why he has to babysit but he doesn't
mind it gives him something to watch as
he snacks on the grass finally some
respect unbelievable
chin up mr. pip you're still a hero in
our hearts
another hero from doggy Doo good
his recent graduate Sammy Sammy
transitioned to his forever family only
five months ago but his bond with
handler Bryce has been immediate Sammy
helps Bryce with several diagnoses
including generalized anxiety disorder
ADHD inflammatory bowel disease and
bipolar disorder one way Sammy AIDS
Bryce is during Bryce's regular blood
draws before going into an appointment
Sammy gives Bryce hugs and pressure
helping to prepare the boy for the
anxiety the noodles cause during the
draws
Sammy gives Bryce constant pressure to
help him feel more comfortable Sammy
knows Bryce isn't in distress now but
the 18-month old lab checks in
constantly making sure if Bryce ever
needs him he's there
while Bryce's family had always had
animals at first they weren't sure about
adding a service dog the support that
Sammy's provided in only his first few
months however has made it all worth it
someday the puppies in training will
have similar bonds with their owners and
be just as important to a family as
Sammy's
[Music]
back with the student pups it's time for
a long walk on the beach or at least
next to it Remy's had a big day so
trainer paul takes this walk very slow
whenever Remy begins to pull away or
move in a different direction the
trainer stops this teaches Remy to stay
focused during a heel the puppies need
to be paying attention to the handler
constantly not drifting away on their
own line eventually Remy starts to do
better on the stairs heel is even more
difficult for these pups dogs want to be
on even ground and prefer bolting up and
down steps the people they'll someday
aide however may need help with stairs
so it's important the puppies learn
patience to end her day Paul works with
Remy on one of her special abilities hug
as difficult as the day has been for the
young Holden it's important to remember
that someday she'll be a huge comfort to
a lucky family it's going to take work
and patience but it's clear it'll be
worth it
[Music]
some dogs can become nervous on the pier
as the spaces between the uneven
surfaces can be uncomfortable under
their paws not our mr. pip though he
even finds the time to get in some of
his best down-stay work to date good boy
mr. pip nice as the day winds down Paul
begins to test a special skill of kaya
steady steady allows people with
mobility issues to put pressure on a dog
to sit down stand up or just regain
their balance it's one of Deakin
specialties and might someday because as
well knowing her eight month old joints
are still developing Paul puts only the
lightest of pressure over her legs once
she's grown she'll be able to take much
more weight and may even wear a harness
like Deakin
at the end of the day some dogs took
steps forward while others steps back
for all these puppies though it's still
too soon to tell
who will flunk out who will graduate
puppy brat
[Music]